[Musique]
il n'y a pas de charly lesquelin mima
les naissains pied a grandi tampon la
vie saint joseph depuis un bon bout de
temps et l'atelier well as depuis plus
de 11 ans commence par avoir un crp de
dessin publicitaire dans les années 80
quelques années après dans les années 90
on voit comment ça fait de mes premiers
tableaux mais était dur donc je suis
allé au conseil de williams dit mon
monde allons émettre mais ma partie fait
de portraits un chemin mois participent
à une bonne boutique réole etc
quant à gauche et la madame a fait des
portraits un florilège dans dans des
devant les grandes surfaces dont
beaucoup étaient dans la rue donc la
main d'avoir fait les faits main donc
avec les faits main avec l'association
arts et traditions dans les années
quatre deux mille n'appartient à paris
au carrousel du louvre et l'ama a vu ma
découvre paris les expos les musées les
tableaux de maîtres et la lamal envie de
voyager vraiment et de rentrer dans ce
monde là bas tu es dedans donc m'a
exposé de 2000 à 2010 à paris avec un
prix au carrousel du louvre en 2008 près
de peinture le prix guy ces radios et le
début de l'histoire internationale en
avec l'invitation en thaïlande puis en
chine puis l'ims depuis l'indonésie la
malaisie où les musiciens mater leader
d'un groupe qui a pris mon doigt langue
du reggae donc là où vraiment des portes
aussi de chanter maloya août sega ou des
chansons internationales aussi ma
représente le plus dignement possible
mon île au niveau international et ceci
depuis mes plus grandes fiertés de
sorbonne chemin et d'avoir grimpé en
main en essayant d'amener le maximum de
dentiste a évolué toute une génération
parce que les pas facile du tout ma
commencent les autres pays sur la toile
mais moins qu'on me décrire météo q&a
dimanche attendait pas une toile monter
la case midi mais moins vite panne et il
avait des remarques de la cour ont donc
matt rappelé au banc drogba khaimah
commence pas de fûts m'a fait des têtes
d'esclaves des scènes de lit à l'escale
âge parce que c'était à fin décembre
et du coup mme avant tout premier jour
là m'a compris qu' il faut aussi est un
peu contestataire montrer un peu dans ma
province usa auront du mal à poser leur
question cherche pourquoi pourquoi il
toucha au en fait l'atelier au fil du
temps comme le disait avec mon camarade
mika boyer l'est devenu un art social
club
beaucoup d'artistes débat vient il il
promet énergie cherché à aider mon aîné
le projet tiré ma miley dès la fin
d'année dernière
l'aîné comme ça les néons qui s'abat
simonet tableau le moigne achetés les
tableaux et sachez le monde de la
culture la réunion il fonctionne parce
que les gens qui savent avec un tableau
et les soudures alaba sécuriser tout
avec eux
collienne et la partie comme une traînée
de poudre
lorsque tous les artistes attendent et
de vouloir donner à fait mais séparément
rime à rien par contre si on met toutes
ensemble d'un seul coup en france et
c'est ce que la spa s'est inventé les
colonies évidemment là il ya un muet et
heureusement mais pas toutes les
promesses que l'été fait à l'époque pour
mon corps a été réalisée aujourd'hui
notre beaucoup d'inégalités donc ces
deux économies prône pour l'entré deux
le peuple par le peuple
faudrait se rassemblent et donc c'est
pas gagné faut continuer
[Musique]